y aquí en la casa blanca con pegado del
salón de prensa donde normalmente el
presidente de sus discursos sin embargo
entrando esta tarde a la casa blanca
hablé con uno de los oficiales de prensa
que le dijo que no que don otro no se
pronunciará públicamente hoy un poco lo
ha hecho en sus redes sociales y pues
eso ha tenido con bastante expectativa
con bastante pues mucho que pensar ha
dejado también precisamente sobre el
hecho de que donald trump o no haya
respondido ni siquiera en sus redes
sociales también pues estuvimos
averiguando con oficiales acá si hay
respuesta por parte de la campaña lo que
nos dicen es que ellos quieren esperar
el conteo quieren esperar los litigios
quieren esperar pues que se desarrolle
se termine de contar todos los votos en
los diferentes estados para entonces
hacer más un pronunciamiento oficial
sobre pues la reacción y lo que pasó hoy
pues teniendo un nuevo presidente electo
con muchos casos de champaña que esteban
un tema muy interesante sobre el que
manejas información muy precisa tiene
que ver con la composición de los votos
no según diferentes factores edad género
origen contanos al respecto
y eso es importante saber quién al final
votó por joe by en las mujeres fueron
las que más votaron en comparación con
los hombres 53 por ciento de las mujeres
en eeuu aptas para votar terminaron
votando por el candidato demócrata esto
obviamente según información que provee
el 'new york times' el 51 por ciento de
los hombres terminó votando por donald
trump en cuanto a pues los grupos
sociales en cuanto a las razas acá en
eeuu como le dicen los afroamericanos
12% de los afroamericanos aptos para
votar terminaron votando por donald
trump el 87% de los afroamericanos voto
por joe biden lo que tiene que ver con
los asiáticos el 16% de los asiáticos
terminó votando por
donald trump sin embargo el restante
terminó votando por yo bailé lo que
tiene que ver con los latinos una
población que además en la población que
más creció en número de personas aptas
para votar comparándolo con otras
minorías en eeuu y pesquera de tanta
importancia para republicanos y
demócratas el 33% de los latinos en eeuu
terminó votando por el presidente joe
donald trump perdón y el restante 66 por
ciento lo hizo por joe biden es es
importante mencionar que es los latinos
en la florida pues terminaron dándoles
sobre todo su apoyo
'no no tontería y la victoria en ese
estado clave entregaba 29 votos
electorales sin embargo pues los latinos
tanto en nevada como en arizona que son
los estados donde recientemente en los
ojos de la nación estaban puestos pues
fueron los latinos allá que terminaron
apoyando mucho más a job ayer para que
fuera el próximo presidente electo el
presidente número
46 en lo que tiene que ver con la
sociedad blanca en los hombres blancos
como dicen acá pues la mayoría terminó
votando por dona